the first couple days were really a blur
you're in the hospital you're drugged up
they do surgery to stabilize the spine I
remember uh nurse you know coming in and
she was being you know very helpful and
everything oh you know you'll get out of
here and have a you know a wheelchair
and your friends will call you you know
give you a nickname like wheels or
something like that she was trying to be
nice but I didn't take that the greatest
way because I didn't want to be in a
wheelchair of my life I wanted to walk
well I'm David from Winter Garden
Florida and I grew up in Michigan little
town club Ludington Michigan right on
the beach so the fun place to grow up my
parents have a Christmas tree farm so we
grew up with a farm life that involved a
lot of early mornings so I think you
know I learned a lot of sort of you know
really disciplined from that and in high
school you know I was kind of a you know
played sports big well in class sort of
thing but I was definitely a math and
science person so when I went to school
at the University of Michigan I went
into engineering and chemical
engineering to be specific because I got
towards graduation I kind of figured I
would go into oilfield services I was
going to work one of those companies out
in the field out on the rigs you know
on the gulf of north wherever would have
been because I liked working outdoors
I was out celebrating the end of school
and I had a little bit too much to drink
and led to some poor decision where I
actually fell off a second-story porch
and that was about a 10 to 12-foot fall
and I landed on my back and crossed my
spinal cord and because of that I have a
mail to move my legs or Milwaukee
dependently for 14 years now it was a
huge change for guy who was just about
ready to go out beyond gone could
suddenly be completely dependent upon
friend the family again
probably getting out of the hospital in
those six nine months after I was out
was probably the most difficult time you
know because you're not getting out as
much as he used to and just getting out
amongst people and friends you know it
was a big part of staying positive and
sort of keeping your spirits up
so there was a lot of tough stuff in
there but I knew how you know I kind of
thought maybe not like the annulment I
had gold that I still you know could
read and I knew that I wasn't going to
just be able to you know hop out of the
chair and go run or walk that obviously
was not in the cards and so I remember
being at my parents house you know maybe
six months after the injury and my dad
say well if you don't you want to go out
and try and do some of this so we went
out into the driveway and my parents
driveway is a little hill to it and so
we parked the wheelchair at the bottom
and I got up on the walker fortunately
my dad was walking the wheelchair behind
me in case I got tired I probably went
ten steps and then just fell back into
the wheelchair but we went out and we do
it the next day and it was a few more
steps and you know day after that I
would look few more steps and you know
it's just it's a long long process but
it was
and then after that it was obviously
well you know what am I going to do
after
so I had crushed my back and I was you
know working on getting more independent
and obviously at this point I'm just on
Social Security disability which is you
know you're basically living at the
poverty level it's going to be a very
difficult life if I was going to do that
the rest of my life so you know I knew
that my mind was fine you know I can
still process you know things that way
so I started looking at ways where I
could continue to use my engineering
degree and one of the ways that I came
up with was an law which is a field of
law worry basically you're helping
people to get patents on their new
inventions or you're researching their
new inventions that sort of thing and so
I applied to a few different law schools
then I got accepted to the University of
Miami and so I graduated with about
$75,000 two months I'd start paying back
to the minimum payments you know month
my mom and and you're going to be paying
on those for 20 years or whatever it is
getting out of debt you know has a lot
of parallels with you know me coming
from an jury to the point where I could
walk again because you know at the very
beginning both of those goals were so so
far away you know if I had had sat in
the chair the whole time I was never
going to be able to build it up to the
point where I could walk you know a
hundred feet or 500 feet or a thousand
feet and it's the exact same thing with
your debt you know if you look at that
number and get frustrated from the
beginning you're never going to start
so four years out of law school I've
been paying the minimum payment on the
student loan and it is slowly whittled
its way down to about seventy thousand
dollars and I had also been saving up
for and bought a brand-new truck during
this time so I bought the truck but of
course I had the student loan debt and
right around this time I'd also
purchased the house
I was driving in the truck one day and I
had heard Dave Ramsey before on the
radio he must have taken a call or been
talking to somebody that day and he was
talking about the risk that your debt
carries and I hadn't really thought of
it that way before because I could well
I got a job I can make the payment on my
food loans I can pay my mortgage mail
but he mentioned you know something
could happen you could get hurt if there
ever was that was the turning point in
my debt free journey where I finally
began to hear what David was saying and
to hear you know what type of risk debt
posed in my life and so I got home that
night and I wrote out my budget and
started doing it exactly the way the D
teaches where you know you're not
looking backwards at your money you're
looking forward and by this time of
course I'm listening to Dave
pretty regularly on a podcast and it
really fires you
I can make my extra money if I work
extra so I took extra work you know I'd
work you know in the evenings rather
than watching from television or I'd
work a little bit on the weekend instead
of sleeping in late and so you know this
money just starts you know hammering at
the student loan and less than two years
later it was gone you know once I did
that you know I took a look over at my
mortgage so what kind of debt is the 252
well there was a student loan from law
school in there and my mortgage you paid
off your house and your law school debt
exactly just like that
I guess one of the ways that I look at
it is that I don't have it that bad
there's always somebody else out there
that we've been through something even
worse I think the reason that I used to
decide to get out of debt was you know
you hear the relief in people's voices
when they're calling in today's show on
their debt free you know just being able
to take that that sort of stress out of
your life you know allows you to sleep
so much better you can focus on other
things in your life your friends your
family your relationships your health
you know there's no reason for me to sit
at home and feel sorry for myself and
say well like you know I can't
accomplish this you know yeah of course
you can accomplish it
but it's going to be hard work and you
need to be willing to put that work in
to do it the grand whole debt that I pay
off with two hundred fifty two thousand
dollars and it just it happens faster
than you think it's going to happen
you know start today start tomorrow they
get started because you know a year from
now five years from now ten years from
now you'll thank yourself for doing that
I'm debt free